Hello, everyone. This
is Isaac Kurtzer of
the Department of
Biomedical Science, Old
Westbury campus. And
this will be the first of
two lectures on cranial
nerve nuclei. This
one concerning those
cranial nerve nuclei
related to cranial
nerves 1, 2, 3, 4 and 6.
We have three objectives
for this lecture.
First, you need to
identify the cranial
nerves for vision,
olfaction, and eye
behavior. Next, identify
the cranial nerve nuclei
for eye behavior and
its coordination.
And lastly, you need
to locate injuries
to these pathways given
particular deficits
and residual
capabilities. As always,
NOLTI is a great
resource, but there'll be
complimentary information
from many resources
available online we
begin with cranial nerve
1 which subserves the
sense of smell not
surprisingly the
afferents for this system
are found within the
nasal cavity so it can
detect odorants that
enter in through the
nostril the cell bodies
for these afferents are
within the olfactory
bulb so the nerve
itself these afferents
these axons are passing
through little pores in
this bone the crivoform
plate now those first
order neurons will
then synapse on second
order neurons that
are within the olfactory
bulb and those axons
of the second order
afferents will be
traveling along the
olfactory tract to target
piriform cortex among
other structures so this
is notable in two
respects first the nerve
actually is going to
end at within that bulb
there'll be that'll
be the end of that
nerve to be precise this
is moving on inwards
this tract these are
second-order neurons
that's one number two this
system is not directly
yoked to a cranial
nerve nuclei which is
going to be different
from all the other
CNs will be examining
except for number two
the last part is that
it is unique for all
modalities to be able
to reach cerebral cortex
without going through
thalamus. Remember
thalamus is the gateway
to cortex and this
system decided to just
skip it. Why is that?
Because it was there
before you had it. This
is a very ancient
modality and it's going to
be targeting a very
ancient region of cerebral
cortex that is
paleocortex. All these
other areas that you're
much more familiar
with besides piriform,
like, oh, I know frontal
lobe. I've heard of
parietal lobe. We had
a bunch of lectures
on the occipital lobe.
That is all temporal
lobe. Go on and on. This
is all neocortex. The
piriform cortex is
ancient, and it's
going to be processing
information from this
ancient sensory modality.
Pagnozmia is the loss
of smell, the loss
of olfactory
sensation, and it can
occur specific to one
nasal passage, and
because of that, you
should test both.
We do not have
very good spatial
localization with
our sense of smell.
And because of that,
you may not realize
that you have a deficit
in smell. And so that's
why it needs to be
specifically tested.
Now,
the olfaction can be
disrupted at the level
of the cranial nerve
in a variety of
ways. You can be
having that bulb being
moved over that
ribiform plate, and that
would shear those first
-order afferents that
are passing on
through. So any, like a
car wreck, could lead
to a loss of smell.
You could have tumors
or some abscess
that applies pressure
on the tract.
That would be disrupting
as well. And lastly,
there are a number
of clinical.
There's a number of
pathologies that are
first manifested in a
loss of sense of smell.
And so this became well
known with COVID-19.
Right. But we also have
Parkinson's disease.
So Parkinson's disease,
one of the earliest
signs is a loss of
sense of smell. So
this should be
generally queried to the
patient. And this is
not because of central
processing per se. It's
at the earliest stage
of sensory transduction
because those Lewy
bodies that are a one
sign of Parkinson's
disease are found within
the olfactory bulbs.
Cranial nerve 2 subserves
our sense of vision.
Sensory processing
begins in the retina, a
multilayered structure
whose retinal ganglion
cells send axons that
form the optic nerves
and there's a partial
decussation at the
optic chasm and after
this um crossing over
point we have the
optic tract let it be
emphasized that the
same axons are involved
throughout this portion
of their course it's
not as if there is a
synapse it's just a
change in the naming
convention so the very
same axons are traveling
along through or
alongside the optic chiasm
they have three main
targets one would be
the lgn which is a
thalamic nucleus that
will be sending its
information to the
occipital lobe two we have
the superior colliculus
that will be receiving
collateral inputs
and third we have the
pre-tectile area and
so the pre-tectile area
is going to enable
the pupillary light
reflex which is a
visosensory feedback response
and notably the pre
-tectile area which
I'm not showing you in
this image it's in fact
rostral to this midbrain
section that pre
-tectile area will be
sending its outputs
bilaterally to the
editing westfall nucleus
so the pre-tectile area
of the left side will
be targeting the left
and right editing
westfall nucleus and
the same for the right
pre-tectile area will
be targeting the left
and the right editing
Westfall nucleus which
will be supporting
this pupillary light
reflex which will cover
more in subsequent
slides of the brain
with the temporal lobes
largely excised allows
us to have a better
idea of the flow of
information from the optic
chiasm to the superior
colliculus or to
the thalamus and then
from the thalamus to
the occipital lobe via
the optic radiations.
Vision can obviously
be compromised in a
variety of ways. damage
to cerebral cortex damage
to the internal capsule
there's also damage
at the early stage of
processing so here's
a small list of ways
we could have damage
early on well the eye
itself is poorly protected
by the eyelids so any
trauma to it looks
likely cause severe
damage it's a very
metabolically active the
retina because there's
so much information
processing going on so
that means that you have
to have a steady and
reliable supply of
blood and so disorders
that interfere with
that like diabetes or
glaucoma are going to
quickly lead to vision
problems of permanent
vision problems so we have
it's a the nerves are
myelinated in order
to reliably and quickly
relay the sensory
information so multiple
sclerosis will strongly
impact vision at this
peripheral stage and
so this is just a small
list there are many
others ways of interfering
with so we have
three nerves to cover
and their associated
nuclei and associated
actions and associated
interrelations and
dysfunction for the rest of
the lecture that's
cranial nerve three, four
and six. And so that
would also be called
the ocular motor nerve,
which is linked to
the ocular motor nucleus,
the trochlear nerve,
which is no way to
the trochlear nucleus
and the abducens nerve,
which is linked to
the abducens nucleus.
All of those have
somatomotor functions,
and you'll see that the
nuclei are situated on
the midline. there's
also the editing
Westfall nucleus which is
very nearby the ocular
motor nucleus together
to call the ocular
motor complex and this
will have a visceral
motor function to drive
the soft muscles of
the iris we'll be
showing this cartoon of
the realistic cartoon
of the brain stem with
the cerebellum removed
and looking at it
from a dorsal vantage,
you might recall the
superior colliculi and
then this is the wall
of the fourth ventricle
for reference. So the
ocular motor nucleus
and erring west bone
nucleus are both found
within the midbrain
they're near the mid
line as are all the other
nuclei they're going
to be controlling eye
movements we see abducens
here and then there's
trochlear oh you
can't see my pointer
here's abducens here and
trochlear over here
also within the midbrain
so note that all the
motor nuclei for the
cranial nerve nuclei we
are interested in for
both lexers are listed
on the left while
the sensory nuclei are
listed on the right
we'll be repeating this
image again and again
here's another semi
-realistic cartoon showing
the brain stem with
the motor nuclei on one
side sensory nuclei
on the other there are
cranial nerves shown
emanating from the
medulla pons and midbrain
I had put a box around
the the nuclei that
are actually the nerves
that are under discussion
along with their
nuclei that
they're linked to
within each
designation for a
nuclei I don't
know let's just say
trigeminal motor I'm
jumping ahead there'll
be in parentheses the
nerve that's associated
with So going back
over here, the
ocular motor nucleus is
associated with cranial
nerve 3. Editing
Westphal nucleus is
associated with cranial
nerve 3. So whenever
you need to try to
think about what is the
nerve associated with
this nucleus, well,
that information is
provided right in front
of you. So that we
have two views of two
cartoon realistic
cartoon views of the
cranial nerve nuclei
and nerves as situated
within the brainstem. I
will not be discussing
each one of these
again and again and
again, double dipping
on that, but they
will be in the PowerPoint
for you to see and
examine and learn from
it. your pleasure.
We have a transverse
section through the
rostral midbrain. So it
would be corresponding
to a cut through the
superior colliculi.
You could recognize
also the cerebral
aqueduct and the cerebral
peduncles as dead
giveaways that we are
within the midbrain.
The ocular motor
nuclei are going to be
midline structures as
well as the editing
westfall nuclei and their
axons are going to be
traveling out through,
exiting through the
cerebral peduncles
on the anterior side.
The editing westfall
will be controlling
the lens in the pupil
while the ocular motor
will be controlling
several eye muscles.
so the somatic motor
function of cranial
nerve three is to
control the eyes and the
eyelids there are four
muscles of the eyes that
receive their input from
a given ocular motor
nucleus three of them
ipsilateral to the
ocular motor nucleus
that is the ocular motor
nucleus This is going
to be providing synaptic
input, neuromuscular
junction onto these
three muscles, medial
******, inferior
******, and inferior
oblique. So medial ******,
inferior ******, and
inferior oblique because
it's approaching it
from an oblique angle.
All of those are going
to be coming, the
innervation for all of
those will be originating
from the ipsilateral
oculomotor nucleus.
The control of the
superior ******
will be originating
from a contralateral
oculomotor nucleus,
I'm kind of
drawing it into their
head, contralateral
oculomotor
nucleus. And also,
the eyelid would be
controlled by the
contralateral ocular
motor nucleus.
Cranial nerve 3
also houses visceral
efferents that have their
origin in the editing
westfall nucleus,
which is part of the
ocular motor complex.
The axons from the
editing westfall
nucleus travel down the
cranial nerve three
to target the ciliary
ganglion on the
ipsilateral side. and from
there they'll be
activations of the
smooth muscles that
will contract the pupil
and smooth muscles
that will change the
shape of the lens again
this is ipsilateral
control so the editing
Westfall nucleus
on the left side of
the brain will control
the pupil and lens
of the left eye by
the end of this lecture
you'll be familiar
with this cartoon of
the two eyes the six
muscles for each eye the
nerves which innervate
the muscles of the
eyes and the origin
of those nerves in
particular nuclei
including their patterns
of decussation and so
I just thought this is
a good place to start
and you know have orient
yourself to seeing
well if there's a
lateral ****** medial
****** these dashed
lines are trying to
indicate that the
innervation to a muscle
originated from a
contralateral fiber I also
want to point out this
rule that the nerves
always control the
ipsilateral side so once
you see the nerve
it means that it has
exited the CNS it will
target a a tissue on
that very same side
via a smooth muscle or
striated muscle or
having a sensory organ.
Nerves are ipsilateral
tract can be
contralateral. um
they can be bilateral
and they are typically
um ipsilateral but
we don't have that
that flexibility
those that kind of
ambiguity you can say
when it comes to the
nerves the nerves
are unambiguously
always ipsilateral
each cranial nerve will
branch into a superior
and inferior division
that will control
the musculature of a
given eye the superior
division is going
to carry efferents
targeting the superior
****** and levator probably
the eyelid muscle
and these efferents
will be originating
from the contralateral
oculomotor nucleus the
ipsilateral oculomotor
nucleus and editing
westbone nucleus are
going to be sending
efferents through the
inferior division of the
ocular of the cranial
nerve 3 targeting
that eye the muscles
innervated vis-a-vis the
inferior division are
the medial ******
inferior ****** inferior
oblique and the
parasympathetics to control
the lens and pupil of
that eye systematic
relation of cranial
nerve 3 superior and
inferior divisions in
terms of whether they
are conveying information
from the contralateral
ocular motor nucleus
or ipsilateral
respectively provides a
window into identifying
the locus of the
lesion whether originates
in the brainstem or
in the cranial nerve so
a unilateral brainstem
lesion will have
ipsilateral lower branch
symptoms and
contralateral upper branch
symptoms that is for
the superior ****** and
the eyelid muscle the
unilateral cranial
nerve lesions will
only have ipsilateral
symptoms they may not
have all of them but
whatever they will be
will be on the same side
as we saw before cranial
nerve three relays
a variety of efferents
and it's that variety
which creates a
variety of symptoms
expressed during cranial
nerve three palsies
so we have four images
here the first is
showing ptosis or the
dropping of the eyelid
and this is going to be
reflecting dysfunction
in the superior
division and that could
be originating in the
contralateral ocular
motor nucleus we have
the medial ******
uh palsy so this
individual is intending to
look to the left with
both eyes, but this
right eye is not
moving. They are unable
to adduct that eye. And
so the medial ******
is controlled by muscle
through efferents
that are passing
through the inferior
division and that would
be um vis-a-vis ocular
motor nucleus on the
same side if we had a
complete lesion of
the uh cranial nerve
three on for one eye
then you would have
weakness of four of the
six muscles and you have
this characteristic
down and out okay so
that would be the the
muscles that remain
engageable are
overactive which would be
the abducens muscle and
the superior oblique
and the net effect
of it is down and
out the last example
here is unequal pupillary
dilation we can see
it's more for this
eye the pupil is
more dilated than for
this eye so that is
anisocoria and so
anisocoria and this
is unequal aniso means
unequal so anisocoria
is going to reflect
a problem that is
manifested in one eye
being more open to other.
It could be weakness
or paralysis of
the control of the
sphincter per se and
that would be a lesion
specific to the
inferior branches or it
could reflect something
much more serious.
Now let us return to
the pupillary light
reflex because we've
covered cranial nerve
two and we've
three and we can put
it all together so it
should be obvious that
if I snip the cranial
nerve two or if I
damage the retina
regardless that eye
is effectively blind
and light shines into
a blind eye can't
transmit any information
so in this case the
pupil will not change
its diameter neither
will be any change
on the other eye,
as long as you've
made sure that
you're just shining
light into one.
Interestingly, there
can be a pupillary
response in a blind
eye if one was to shine
light in the normal eye,
that is the eye that
has an intact cranial
nerve 2 and an intact
cranial nerve 3. And
this would be because
cranial nerve 2 will
target the pre-tectile
area which sends
projections to both
editing westfall nuclei.
So the editing westfall
nuclei on both sides
will be innervated
by the pre-tectile area
of a given side. And
so now both editing
Westfall nuclei will
relay their activity
vis-a-vis the cranial
nerves to each of the
pupils pupillary muscles
leading to a constriction
so this is called
a consensual response
and this is a
important way of peering
into the connectivity
of the neural network
at what point is
something broken so if
you are able to elicit a
consensual reflex of
this eye that did not
respond on its own you
know that the different
arm that controls
the pupil is intact.
Another example
of dissecting
the underlying
dysfunction given
the known connectivity
and the patterns
of pupillary responses
to light in one eye
or the other is the
following. Let's just
say that a given
eye does not show a
pupillary response either
when you shine light
to it directly or
shine light on the
contralateral eye and
you know that this eye
with the dilated
pupil can in fact see.
Then you know
that the other eye
can see and also
shows a pupillary
response then you
can track down the
dysfunction to
one of two places
we have the efferent
limb of the reflex itself
that is not able to
activate the pupillary
muscles on that side
or it could be the
ocular motor complex
which would include the
editing Westfall nucleus
that could be impacted.
So this information
of or this pattern of
responses will allow
you to track down some
but not yet all and
to distinguish between
these two you would have
to do further tests.
There's a variety of
ways for which you
could have damage
to the cranial nerve
three it could be
physically compressed
from head injury
like some trauma and
the parenchyma moving
around it have to
be violent but that
could happen you
could have a vascular
problem such as a
****** within the
midbrain you can have
inflammation of a
tissue that is in the
neighborhood you can
have a tumor and so
there are many different
ways that you can
push against and
otherwise degrade cranial
nerve 3 we talked about
multiple sclerosis
the list goes on now
we move on to the
cranial nerve for the
trochlear nerve which
is linked to the
trochlear nucleus found in
the midbrain immediately
located nucleus
just underneath the
ocular motor nucleus
which is within the
midbrain medially placed
Another view of
the trochlear nerve
nucleus, which is found
within the loomose
portion of the
midbrain. It's medially
placed underneath the
ocular motor nucleus.
Cranial nerve 4, aka
trochlear nerve, has
some simple features
and some complex,
if not peculiar,
features. The simple
features include that
it is carrying efferents
from just one
nucleus, the trochlear
nucleus, and those
efferents are targeting
just one muscle, the
superior obliques.
The peculiarities
are it's the
only nerve
that leaves the
brainstem dorsally,
and that's one.
Two, it also has a
tract that decussates,
that is, within the
parenchyma, the tract
because nerves don't
decassate meaning that the
left trochlear nucleus
is going to innervate
the right superior
oblique and vice versa
the left superior left
trochlear nucleus will
innervate the right
superior oblique now
it's a very small perineal
nerve the smallest
of the bunch and it
has the longest course
that it must make the
journey from its exiting
to innervating that
muscle is the longest
because it's exiting
from the dorsal side
trochlear nuclei are
found at the level of
the caudal midbrain
we're not going to be
able to see those nuclei
themselves they're
so very small this
is kind of cartoon
form of finding where
we generally are
going to be around but
i will take the time
to point out how we
know that we're at the
caudal midbrain and
that these swelling
large swellings that
we see at the back
which are most certainly
tectum that these
are inferior colliculi
because we can see
the decussation of the
superior cerebellar
peduncles uh anterior
to that that's the
real sign that we are
at the level of the
inferior colliculus now
we're returning back
to the trochlear
nucleus it'll be very
very small nucleus
located uh around this
level that will have
a decussation within
the uh parenchyma
their inference will
decussate across from
right to left from
left to right within
the parenchyma of the
brain before exiting
out the dorsal side
and staying on that
side, that nerve stays
on that side as it
travels on forward to
innervate the superior
oblique of the eye
on the contralateral
side of the nucleus,
but the ipsilateral
side of the nerve.
as you likely remember
the superior and
inferior ****** have
a origin on the nasal
side so their line
of action is not in
the sagittal plane
hence if they were to
be act let's just say
this ****** muscle,
then it would move
the eye off from the
sagittal plane as it
was moving the eye up.
So in order to keep
the eye moving in
the sagittal plane,
that is to make purely
movements that
look just up, just
down, you're going
to need to engage
an oblique muscle
on the other side.
So the superior ******
is going to have
to have its activity
coordinated with the
inferior oblique, and
the inferior ******
would need to have its
activity coordinated
with the superior
oblique. And then
acting together as
this pair, you would
be able to keep the
eye in the sagittal
plane as you elevated
it or depressed it.
Trochlear nerve palsies
can be evident in
a few different signs
shown by the patient.
You can see if it's
prominent enough,
you might be able
to readily see the
deviation of that one
eye upwards and inwards
as they attempt
to look straight
ahead. They might
tilt their head to the
unaffected side to
compensate for this.
Alternatively, it
might be a little bit
more subtle. You
really have to give a
good look to see that,
and the person comes
in with a direct
complaint that they
have double vision
in the vertical axis.
And it contested that
it's worse as they
look downward. This is
a very serious situation
in terms of navigating
a world that includes
stairs. You know
where to place your
foot. This is not where
you want to have double
vision now the cranial
nerve 4 is a very
thin nerve because of
very few axons it has
a very long course
which makes it very
delicate so it's susceptible
to injury all the
way along that along
and along that way and
interestingly enough
most of at least many
of the cases appear
to be congenital this
may actually be most,
but it's hard to tell.
Now we're moving
on to cranial
nerve 6, the abducens
nerve associated
with the
abducens nucleus.
Like the nuclei
for the other eye
muscles, it will have
a medial location
here within the
pons. Another view of
the location of the
abducens nucleus,
being medial pons.
And here's one last
view of the location
of the abducens
nucleus within the pons
found within the
tegmentum of the pons. I
want to point out a
couple other things.
We see the long
length of the axons as
they course throughout
the parenchyma of
the brain and exiting
out the ventral side
being the most medial
of the three nerves
located on the
pontomedullary junction.
And also point out
these tracks at the
furthest most dorsal
portion of the brainstem
medially this is the
medial longitudinal
fasciclus so this is
a paired structure
that we can see in
many different sections
of the brainstem and
it's going to be carrying
information that
is critical for eye
movements involving
the vestibular organs
and involving
communication between two
different cranial nuclei
as you'll soon see.
Cranial nerve six is
the abducens nerve as
linked to just a single
nucleus the abducens
nucleus and that
nerve will be carrying
efference fibers to
innervate the lateral
****** on the same
side enabling abduction
so the right abducens
nucleus will enable
the right eye to move
right words it's the
most common paralysis
that is seen in terms
of isolated motor
palsy and this is owing
in part to that long
course that it must
make to in to innervate
the eye muscle the
number of ways that it
can be disrupted ranges
from trauma to diabetes
there's a diabetic
neuropathy now when
you have a palsy of
this eye and I'm going
to be circling this
individuals eye which
is affected because
they're attempting to
look directly at us
and unintentionally
this eye is is adducting
and so they call
that esotropia like
esophagus so that's
inner esoteric esotropia
and so these individuals
would be suffering
from double vision in
the horizontal axis.
This can be treated
with glasses so
a very really simple
fix all things
considered or one
could have a more
serious course in
terms of surgery.
A
couple slides back
I was mentioning the
medial longitudinal
fasciclus. This is not
cranial nerve 6. It is
related to the abducens
nucleus insofar as
it will be sending
collateral fibers through
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus. There's
fibers from other
nuclei that will be
traveling through the medial
longitudinal
fasciculus such as from
vestibular nuclei for
example but we're just
focusing on those fibers
that are arising from
the abducens nucleus
and this is going to
go from the abducens
nucleus to the
contralateral ocular motor
nucleus that is going
to enable quote
conjugate lateral gaze it
means that you're
moving both your eyes to
the left both of the
eyes to the right okay
that's that that's the
behavior and of course
given it's a paired
structure it will have
a more kind of focused
role in that behavior
which we'll be going
through shortly now
the longitudinal
fasciculus is shown on
the right at two
different sections of the
brain stem here we're
within pons and here
we're within uh caudal
medulla so it's these
darkly stained tracks
that are thin and
paired these columns
of fibers that would be
abutting the para
-aqueductal gray in the
midbrain now the medial
longitudinal fasciculus
itself can be
affected by multiple
sclerosis that can
affect pretty much all of
these nerves, but
this is a very common,
it's commonly affected
because it's highly
myelinated, brainstem
strokes, head trauma,
and Arnold Chiari
malformations because of
the pressure that is
going to be exerted
on the brainstem.
This is that image
that we've seen before
with the six muscles
of the eye, the various
nuclei that can
control the eye and we
have this cartoon
representation of the
communication from the
abducens nucleus to
the contralateral
ocular motor nucleus is
called a medial
longitudinal fasciculus
there's a cartoon the
these are actually
much more vertically
oriented they'd be
crossing over almost
immediately but this is
just for didactic Now
that we've gone over
the neural control
for all of the muscles
of the eye, we're
going to consider some
canonical movements
of the eyes and
understand how those are
enabled by engagement
of the particular
cranial nerve nuclei.
the two eyes upwards
and have them
remain within the
same sagittal plane is
something that can
be achieved by the
engagement of the
two ocular motor
nuclei and no other
nuclear involvement.
And that is because
the movement of each
eye is enabled by the
proper paired activity
of the superior ******
and the inferior
oblique. Remember,
it's the oblique on one
side and the ******
on the other that's
enabled to keep the
motion of the eye moving
vertically without
deviating to the side.
Now, notably, the
control of each eye
involves both ocular
motor nucleus because
the inferior obliques
are going to arise
from the ipsilateral
ocular motor nuclei,
where the innervation
for the superior
****** will arise
from the contralateral
ocular motor nucleus,
and that is also going
to correspond to the
superior and inferior
division of the
nerves to a given eye.
To look downwards
without having the eyes
turned in or out can
be achieved by the
proper coordination
of the superior
oblique and inferior
****** of a given eye.
And these two muscles
are the efferents for
those muscles originate
in different cranial
nerve nuclei so superior
oblique would be
the trochlear nucleus
on the contralateral
side and inferior ******
would be the ocular
motor nucleus on the
ipsilateral side now
we're going to discuss
virgins and accommodation
of the two eyes.
This is important to
properly fixate an
object that is brought
near to the face.
The eyes both must be
rotated inward. That
would be achieved by the
medial ****** of each
eye. And the accommodation
is important insofar
as you need to
make sure that the view
of the object is not
blurred so we need to
change the focal length
of the lens vis-a-vis
the ciliary muscles
and the ciliary muscles
would be innervated
by the editing westfall
nucleus ipsilaterally
and the medial ******
is innervated by
the ocular motor nucleus
ipsilaterally and
both these nuclei have
their efferents relayed
vis-a-vis the cranial
nerve three conjugate
lateral gaze means
that both eyes move
to left or both eyes
move to the right in
order to achieve this
one One must have a
asymmetric pattern of
activity between the two
eyes. They can't be
doing the same things.
The one eye is going
to have to have inner
inner activation of
the lateral ******,
while the other one,
the medial ******,
to ensure that the
two eyes are rotating
the same way in
external space. This is
achieved by the proper
coordination of the
abducens and ocular
motor nuclei vis-a-vis
this MLF that we're
carrying axons from
the abducens to the
ocular motor nucleus.
this image is to show
the eyes being directed
laterally in the other
direction so in this
case you need to have
a flipping of the
which lateral ******
will be engaged and which
medial ****** would
be engaged in both
scenarios if you're going
to be looking left or
right you're going to
have to have the proper
lateral ****** and
medial ******. So to look
left, you have to have
the lateral ******
of the left eye, the
medial ****** of the
right eye. To look right,
you need to have the
lateral ****** of the
right eye and medial
****** of the left eye.
And so it's through
this different behaviors
of looking right,
looking left, that we're
going to try to find
out what is the
circuitry that is damaged
when you see a given
behavior there are three
ways that you can
interfere with lateral
gaze when mucking
up the circuitry
not not the eventual
um the distal cause
that's diabetes or
trauma i'm talking
about the proximal
cause i can snip
the nerve um itself
so a cranial nerve 6
palsy is one way
of disrupting this
coordinated behavior
or i could lesion the
deucin's nucleus this
is called foville's um
disorder or you could
have a lesion to
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus so that's
mlf syndrome and
we're walking through
how each of these
different disruptions
will lead to different
behavioral issues
designate the eye that
we see on the left
side as the left eye
and the eye that we see
on the right side as
the right eye otherwise
it gets quite confusing
let us say that we
snip this abducens
nerve which would result
in the eye on the same
side deviating medially
because you would not
be able to activate
that lateral ******
muscle. And this would
be the case whether
you're attempting to gaze
ahead or to either side.
Now, if one attempted
to look to the left,
then the right eye
would be able to do
that there'd be the
engagement of that medial
****** vis-a-vis the
ocular motor nucleus on
the same side because
the abducens nucleus
on the opposite side
would be sending projections
through the medial
longitudinal fasciculus
for this behavior
so you damage one side
and you affect movement
of the eye on that
side, but the behavior
of the contralateral
eye is appropriate
because the circuit
remains intact over here.
The behavior that would
result from lesioning
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus is
quite different and we
are going to be saying
we're destroying both
of these tracks from
the left to the right
and right to the
left all that's destroyed
so the if one was
to attend to look
left then the left eye
would in fact look left
because the abducens
nucleus and that
abducens nerve retains is
intact and is able to
activate that lateral
****** muscle and even
though this eye does
not have a the right
eye does not have a
damaged nerve and does
not have a damaged
ocular motor nucleus
it is not receiving the
commands to that ocular
motor nucleus from
the contralateral
abducens nucleus and so
this is a going to
be seen on the other
side when you try to look
right so when looking
right the right eye
will be able to look
right because there
is an intact abducens
nucleus and nerve to
activate that lateral
****** muscle and
the left eye remains
immobile even though all
its nerves and nuclei
are intact because
the communication to
the ocular motor nucleus
from the contralateral
abducens nucleus
has been disrupted.
You've lesion the
communication down from
abducens nucleus to the
ocular motor nucleus.
Foyville's is when you
have the disruption
of the abducens nucleus
on one side and this
is going to interfere
with lateral gaze
towards that side you
can see how this could
result from the
disrupted communication
from the abducens nucleus
to the contralateral
ocular motor nucleus
the ocular motor
nucleus will no longer
receive any instructions
that it should engage
that medial ******
to look to the left
and hence it will not
look to the left in
this context it will
move to the left in a
different context of
virgins but not this one
of lateral gaze towards
the side where you
you have the lesion
of the abducens nucleus
and not surprisingly
we have the medial
deviation of the eye
on the same side as
the lesion because the
lateral ****** is
inactive because there is
no longer um a intact
uh commands um from
the um the the center
of its control the
nucleus on that side
for the the nerves that
will target that muscle
have been destroyed
There's a fair
amount of material
for this lecture
to cover these
nerves, cranial nerve
one, two, three,
four, and six,
going over the
individual
functions, their
locations within
the brainstem,
their dysfunctions,
the way they
can be coordinated
together.
This summary provides
you just that. a
summary. I will not
read all this to you.
You can do that on
your own, I trust.
And I hope that
this was clear.
That's complex
material for sure.
I hope I made
it as clear as
possible and feedback
is appreciated.